[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening I'm just I'm Stewart bran
from the long now foundation I'm curious
how many long now members are here yeah
noisy ones too that's good at the end of
the show come on up to the stage will do
the member group photograph as usual
this long slideshow of selfies that we
had there was one quote that kept up
hearing over and over until he got sick
of it but it has a bit of a story that
that might be relevant it's um
I wrote some while ago this present
moment used to be the unimaginable
future but I wrote that as a mirror
statement in answer to Gary Snyder had
written me a couple years ago saying
that he'd written an epigram saying this
present moment leave us on had become
long ago well some of those long ago
moments leave on in film and the very
best collector and curator of that is
Rick Prelinger
[Applause]
thanks Stuart and thank you all for
coming now I can't see any of you so how
many of you have been to all eight shows
before this a handful okay look I think
you know the drill
lost landscapes this is not just about
the city that's gone this is also about
the city that we'd like to live in
I guess that's maybe the long-term
thinking part especially important now
is we're trying to figure out what this
place should be how it should look like
who should live here so think about that
participate I think you know the drill
there are no inhibitions you're all
Groundlings in the Elizabethan sense you
were all rabble but you know Luke I
wanted to say one more thing so lost
landscapes right now as a show here it's
a repeat show at Internet Archive on the
19th of December please tell your
friends there's still tickets left and
it's benefit for a great organization
and occasional repeats here and there
and it lives on the web but you know
it's also something else I can't help
but thinking it it's really been those
feelings been growing at me over the
years that when you get a bunch of
people in a room that represents so many
different communities that it's very
special and I start wondering what else
Lost landscapes could be you know could
it be an archive could it be community
discussions could it be a more active
part of our excellent local history
community and I'd love to figure out a
way to get more people involved in
hunting and gathering and more people
involved in outreach to the many many
san francisco's that we know about and i
don't have time to talk to by myself and
so you know i'm open to talking to
people about this next year I'm very
easy to find but if people have ideas or
they have collaborations you want to
suggest let's do this and make this show
kind of dig deeper deeper into the the
core of this city so look all I have to
say
enjoy yourselves be loud and thank you
so much for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's about 1939
they are in fact
just so you're on the right flight
this is a
1937-38 don't know exactly
look familiar you're looking at shrunken
film that's why it's a little jumpy but
maybe you can
and this is a opening day and these
pictures are courtesy of the Bethlehem
Steel Museum and thanks to Peter linen
Thal for making that connection Potrero
Hill neighborhood History Association
was that tall originally 50 Cent's
raised to 65 litre something like that a
quarter originally okay a lot of money
in the
a little bit of bricked anti-skid
Treasure Island still swampy
key system ole
that's where you would the ferry would
take you on your train to the East Bay
for those of you who haven't seen that
before interestingly enough they're
already working on the some of the
buildings before the island is even
filled in
so this is a rare Hollywood outtake and
this is Harrison Street and here's one
of the last you're gonna see in a minute
one of the last original rincon Hill
houses probably on guessing a post-quake
house don't know what year I think the
bridge is either finished or almost
finished about the same time as this
which is 35 36 37 ish
we've entered the 40s a little bit of
home movie footage
I wondered how long that would be so
somewhere in this group of Scouts is Sam
Ziegler who's in the audience tonight
whose family shot this and this is here
because it just gives there's the Otto
Fred building in the background just
gives you a sense of everyday outside
the Ferry Building in the 30s
where are they going Sam
Boy Scout Jamboree
so this is about 1938 and I've never
seen something so nice Geary Street
looking ahead painless Parker the
dentist on the left
this is a home movie footage
16-millimeter
our busy waterfront
anybody recognize what Street we're on
right somewhere in North Beach
and here's the produce market before it
became the golden gate way it's a
Hollywood background process plate
thrown away by Columbia Pictures long
story
hang on
[Applause]
you're applauding the Embarcadero
Freeway that was an outtake from the
movie the lineup 1957 and then a little
bit of home movie and here's some more
home movies from that 1940s roll
Portsmouth Square
[Applause]
the old Hall of Justice
Portsmouth Square
some of you have gotten to know this
existential runner
this hasn't changed much
a little bit of futurism
you know it's right after the completion
of the Embarcadero Freeway so late 50s
I'd say
some Montgomery block in there if you
look this is from I think Mark Hopkins
this is 520 Pacific this is per sells
black-owned nightclub and supposedly the
first building built after the quake and
this is from about 70 or 71 I've made
this sequence family-friendly I'll just
say that much Romulo place
[Music]
Royall specific is still in business
upper market
right and we're coming coming inbound on
market
this neighborhood has all the stuff
they're trying to build now
Twitter building
coming down six
so this is a background process plate
that was meant to be projected out
behind a car window you'd see people
sitting in a cab and in the back window
this would be projected but we're
repurposing it as evidence so there's a
few empty spaces that are now filled in
and we're coming off of Fillmore Street
I believe
so this is the daughter of the hero Toph
family doctor who roto was a dentist in
the Western Addition and the home movie
collection has a gap in the 40s when the
hero toes were incarcerated in camp but
there's footage before and there's
footage afterwards and this is just a
little bit of their family life in the
Western Addition
so neighborhood fire
again this is somewhere you know I don't
have a date handy it's 38 to 41 probably
yeah I don't
Webster ish someone in the audience is
suggesting we're near Webster Street so
the war is over this is a dr. Hirata and
if you look closely he's wearing his
army jacket and he's got the patch of
the 4-4-2 Valen volunteer military unit
in World War two japanese-americans who
came out of camp old favorite revived
this was shot by John Gorman and it's a
little film he made piece of a little
film he made as a young man and this is
Laurel Hill Cemetery
I have never I've only found one other
piece of film footage of the cemeteries
so this is kind of unusual for those of
you who don't know the cemeteries were
by 1941 they were in the process of
being removed they were kind of derelict
many of the graves had been relocated to
coma but the land hadn't yet been taken
over and redeveloped
right somebody in the Chronicle
described that neighborhood as Trader
Joe's Heights
[Applause]
and a little bit of color footage that
was part of the same shoot
anybody recognize this sake just
we're at aquatic park in 1971
right some of these people have probably
moved to the park
alright coming up on a hundred years so
this film was put together my guess is
some time and in the late teens or early
twenties
and there's a much longer version of
this that you can go online and see but
it doesn't look as good as this and I
tell you in a minute
you'll see something that looks even
better but the crowds are incredible
long march up Van Ness
a little dour
[Applause]
so all of these grand grand buildings
only one of which still survives if
you're interested go to the San
Francisco Public Library sixth floor at
the history room and look at the
photographs of what this place looked
like after the buildings were torn down
it's quite uncanny and amazing lots for
sale February Palace of Fine Arts the
kickoff of the PPI e-100 so this footage
has been years ago it was transferred
from 35-millimeter original to 16
millimeter and then that was transferred
to standard definition videotape and
there's a lot of it's gone through a lot
of generations along the way and most of
the footage we see of the PPI II is is
beat up it it shows the scars of its
long life I don't believe that the 35
millimeter on this still exists I could
be mistaken
sort of a Venetian isn't it except with
submarines but some we had a lot of
35-millimeter material of the ppin our
archives now at Library of Congress and
just this week they sent some material
that has been restored and so I'm gonna
show you material that's never been seen
outside the Library of Congress in a
moment but first the lights
there's a color version of this that's
deteriorated unfortunately
to repeat Strauss who designed the
Golden Gate Bridge design that
so newly restored material this is the
Liberty Bell which was shipped from
Philadelphia to San Francisco crack and
all and it's um it's escort to the fair
and I've included this not because
perhaps it's the most scintillating
material in the world but I want you to
see what hundred year old film can look
like when it gets the profession the
benefit of professional restoration
anybody able to identify anybody
we are now in the 30s and this is Sam
Ziggler's family films ROTC parading not
far from Galileo I think I think if this
might actually be Galileo ROTC
what's that streetcar line and we're at
our Airport Mills Field 1929 for an
airshow
and welcome to the Forman family films
we have a relative we have a relative in
the theater if she has anything to tell
us but no obligation
they're extremely photogenic
here's a little more of SFO in a
different era
two gates
louder Kaitlyn where I believe were on
the mat Sonia about to leave for Hawaii
and you know what people do on boats and
a much earlier departure I think this is
Ziegler family
you've got to get back in the habit of
seeing our friends off
and this is more of the Forman family
films
I don't know where we're leaving from
but and you'll see where we're arriving
since 1957 this is Lawton Street the
caterer
Rambler
and this is 70 or 71 and I think it's
the Columbus Day Parade
the Castroville artichoke float missed
all California or missed all San
Francisco Shriners I believe so high at
Regency under construction
and then is now Justin Herman Plaza
[Applause]
don't know much about this footage it
turned up in an estate sale but it's
beautifully shot
so SOS refers to an effort to to prevent
a ship that was the Coral Sea though is
home ported in Alameda to to sail to
Vietnam this is again this is I think 71
[Applause]
this has been redacted
so the writing Academy on 7th Avenue in
the Richmond District
this was another writing Academy
and notice the station in the background
seventh Avenue Oh 1938 and the park huge
population
the old DeYoung I think this is Sam
Ziegler right cowcatcher she catch her
making it safe San Francisco General
little bit of Potrero Hill and Mission
Bay late 30s new bridge new Island
sometime in the 50s
you can see the Castro by the way in the
with a sign flashing so these are dunes
in the city in the 30 somewhere don't
know where this is the natural state of
San Francisco and this is woody and
David about when are we do you think 38
39 so notice the neighborhood isn't
built up there living across from the
dunes this is Easter
Oliver Russo but look at the dunes yeah
no kidding
still in the Western neighborhoods this
is um this is San Aliso can we identify
these folks there are hipsters yes we
can we can stipulate that
wearing the clothing of the future
we're looking as it vis Valley right
yeah
as our airplane banks don't get too
excited this is um these come from the
collection of rad Dewey's family it's
just a little bit of the fair in 1940
so a year and a half before the war
so donated by Craig Baldwin a little bit
of the haight-ashbury
look remarkably contemporary okay I
think and correct me if I'm wrong that
we are at the beginning of the hippie
period here when the hate hadn't been
sort of HIPPA fide but I'm open to
Corrections
middle-earth
it does look like a redevelopment film
right it's Ben and Jerry's isn't it that
corner
and night is falling and what do people
do at night in the Haight
we go to a light show don't know
anything about this where who are
performance and this now this looks like
the residue of the funeral for the
hippie ceremony the death of hippy but I
wouldn't swear to it
I mean I don't know
right seal Stadium I need to find more
footage of seal stadiums so help me san
Francisco's losing badly
and my tribute to the Giants some of you
have seen this clip before and you know
there's a lot of reasons why I like it
first off it's um it's the it's the
glory and the not-so glory of the past
but you know there's people aren't
there's no heavy merchandising here and
there people wear a cap and people bring
their own orange clothing no but um you
know it's just it's a very it's very
relaxed in fact you'll see at the end
the woman brings her Ritz crackers to
the game instead of buying expensive
Gilroy garlic fries this is an outtake
from the official San Francisco
Convention and Visitor's Bureau film Oh
what do you think it's 60 sometime but I
don't know when early-to-mid
yeah I like the Ritz crackers
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you to Jack Tillman II for that
beautiful piece
so we have a little bit of this is not
recommended a little bit of new footage
of this area and Playland this year
the sky tram
what were the years of the skytram
western neighborhoods please mid mid 50s
to mid 60's
war time 1944 and rainy missed a
fragment the 30s vintage
that's Sam Ziegler Balboa the foot of
Balboa Street
let's make a fast getaway this is also
an outtake from the lineup
this becomes Clement Street it's a point
lobos the extension of Clemente
Fort Miley on the right
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
so this is the first color footage I
found of the Frank H buck in the Ohioan
shipwreck 1937 a very popular tourist
attraction for a while
yeah the big one is the Ohio and right
there still with peace visible at low
tide right piece of the engine block or
something Sutro Baths it ran up on a
rock so this is the Golden Gate Bridge
under construction
again from the Ziegler family films who
had amazing access to the bridge
but the diver just I was delighted to
find this
souvenir rivet
I think they knew somebody
uh-huh
this is before the rainbow
we'll possibly the Robin Williams tunnel
watch your toes and opening day
some of you may remember from past
screenings we won't see this today but
they actually serve drinks on the bridge
that day you could buy booze on the
bridge as part of the celebration
there was a western-themed as you may
remember Polk Street was was set up as a
as a faux western town
business was slow for a while and
sometime in the 40s or 50s we go out to
Golden Gate to the farallon's part of
the city of San Francisco and
supervisorial district one seriously
humans aren't supposed to scare the
animals but they do
and thank you
[Applause]
thank you for coming and thanks to
everyone who helps make these shows
possible
[Music]
you